Does deplatforming violate a speaker's
First Amendment rights?
Senator Josh Hawley has repeatedly
claimed that the cancellation of his
book deal after he challenged the election results
was quote "a direct assault on the First Amendment."
And others suggest that Twitter violated
President Donald Trump's free speech
rights by deleting his account. But this is
a common misconception of our rights.
The First Amendment says that Congress shall
make no law abridging freedom of speech.
The 14th Amendment extends that
prohibition to state and local government.
But with rare exceptions, the Constitution does not place
similar restrictions on private actors.
I can write a letter to the Editor, but
the New York Times is not required to print it.
In fact, forcing the Times or any other private company
to publish statements against its will
violates the publisher's own First
Amendment right to decide what it wishes
to say on its platform. And the same is true of Twitter.
The First Amendment does not protect speech.
It merely prevents the government from
deciding who gets to speak and who does not.
Do you think Twitter's decision to block Trump was just?
Let us know in our poll. Also, let us know
what other topics you'd like our
scholars to cover in 60 seconds,
and be sure to like and subscribe for
more research and videos from AEI.